five weeks ago I spoke to you from the
steps and said that this government was
not going to hang around and that we
would not wait until brexit Day October
the 31st to deliver on the priorities of
the British people and I'm proud to say
that on Wednesday
Chancellor Sajid Javid is going to set
out the most ambitious spending round
for more than a decade I said I wanted
to make your streets safer and that is
why we are recruiting another 20,000
police officers I said I wanted to
improve your Hospital and reduce waiting
times at your GP and so we are doing 20
new hospital upgrades in addition to the
34 billion more going into the NHS and I
said I wanted every child in this
country to have a superb education
that's why I announced last week that we
are leveling up funding across the
country and spending much more next year
in both primary and secondary schools
and it's to push forward this agenda on
these and many other fronts that we need
a Queen's speech in October while
leaving due time to debate brexit and
other matters and as we come to that
brexit deadline I am encouraged by the
progress we are making in the last few
weeks the chances of a deal have been
rising I believe for three reasons they
can see that we want a deal they can see
that we have a clear vision for our
future relationship with the EU
something that has not always perhaps
been the case and they can see that we
are utterly determined to strengthen our
position by getting ready to come out
regardless come up man but if there's
one thing that can hold us back in these
talks it is the sense in Brussels that
MPs may find some way to cancel the
referendum or that tomorrow MPs will
vote with Jeremy Corbyn for yet another
pointless
I don't think they will I hope that they
won't but if they do they will plainly
chop the legs out from under the UK
position and make any further
negotiation absolutely impossible and so
I say to show our friends in Brussels
that we are united in our purpose MPs
should vote with the government against
Corbin's pointless delay I want
everybody to know there are no
circumstances in which I will ask
Brussels to delay we're leaving on the
31st of October no ifs or buts we will
not accept any attempt to go back on our
promises or scrub that referendum and
armed and fortified with that conviction
I believe we will get a deal at that
crucial summit in October a deal that
Parliament will certainly be able to
scrutinize and in the meantime let's let
our negotiators get on with their work
without that sword of Damocles over
their necks and without an election
without an election
I don't want an election you don't want
an election let's get on with the
people's agenda fighting crime improving
the NHS boosting schools cutting the
cost of living unlocking talent and
opportunity across the entire United
Kingdom with infrastructure education
and technology it is a massive agenda
let's come together and get it done and
let's get Rex it done by October the
31st thank you very much